of our first our studio cloud live
series it's actually the first one here
in 2022
so happy new year
also happens to be my little girl's
second birthday today so a lot of
excitement here in my household
now in terms of housekeeping just like
last time we're gonna start with a guest
presenter uh for the first half of the
session and then we're gonna follow with
a live q a
now no need to wait till the
presentation is over um if you have any
questions along the way please just send
them on in and we'll ensure that they
get addressed also if you do have to hop
off early please
don't don't worry we will be recording
this so you can watch it at your leisure
um and at this point i'd like to
introduce today's guest dr patricia
menendez all the way from australia
sharing her experience at the business
stats and econ department within monash
university
pete thanks so much for having me here
today and good morning good afternoon or
good evening and depending on where you
are welcome and thanks for joining us
for this presentation i'm very pleased
to be here
today and i would like to thank pete
and the artist studio cloud team for
giving me the opportunity to share my
experiences
using rs studio cloud with all of you um
this morning here in australia
i'm also very much looking forward to
have a conversation with you and to hear
about your experiences using rstudio
cloud and also answering any questions
that you may have
so without any further ado let's get
started with the presentation
about two and a half years ago i
transitioned from working for the
australian government back into academia
and as a chief examiner i was given the
the task to teach a couple of units on
analytics at the monash business school
and
when i started to to to prepare
the materials and also to think about
the logistics and and also uh to to
think about the delivery i tried to to
recall my experiences both in academia
and outside of academia working with
people who were started to to learn art
and i i really wanted to reflect at that
time what were the
obstacles that
the learners first encountered when they
when they tried to to start their
journey
learning are
and one thing that was very clear to me
was that um
learners at the beginning the the first
burden they face is the installation
of the software
and and also
to get their first project up and
running and i i experienced that
struggles with people outside of
academia
and also with with students in academia
so
um that's what when when i thought that
having a tool that could enable me to
remove those kinds of burdens at the
beginning would be something
very useful and that's what i i thought
about our studio club
so um
when um the copic pandemic hit and we
were here in australia at the beginning
of the semester and suddenly we had to
to change um the whole program and
instead of teaching in classrooms like
the one you see over there which is one
of the classrooms that we have in the
teaching and learning building at monash
university we have to move to a remote
and online teaching and learning
environment and at that time i was
really very very pleased
of the choices that i made before um
even i knew that we would be teaching
remote remotely
that um was using our studio cloud
um
so
in australia when um we had the first
two weeks of the semester
and then we
all all the lectures and tutorials they
were doing online
because of the covet panemia
so
i'm sure many of you have experienced
the same but um
when you teach online and remote
the tools that you use really they they
make a big difference um
and actually in my experience at r
studio cloud it really helped a lot to
to
to go through the semester in a very
smooth way
so let me first tell you a little bit
about the student cohort and the units
that i that i taught using our studio
cloud
um
the students were both undergraduate and
graduate students
and the classroom size range from about
300 students to 60 to 80 students
and in addition to the challenges of of
teaching
remote and online
i also had to
to
to deal with the the issues that the
students in the classroom they have
different knowledge levels and different
coding experience
and
for the undergraduate students some of
them they were first-year students and
the units that i thought were core to
their studies while for some of the
students they the units were elected
and that creates of course a lot of
diversity in in the classroom with the
students knowledge and experiences
and
in particular uh i taught two um units
which are focused on r
the
the first one is introduction to data
analysis
where uh the students they they first
it is an undergraduate unit where the
students first um
encounter are and as i said before some
of the students they are first-year
students and and this is a core unit for
them and some
of the students they take this unit as
an elective so they might come from a
different degree and maybe they have
some experience and coding in other
programming language
and this unit is
taught at the grand undergraduate level
but is also taught at a graduate level
for the students of the master of
business analytics
and that this unit is totally focused on
on using r and get students up to speed
with um data wrangling
a little bit of modeling and and
uh yeah the first encounter with r
the second unit in which i use rstudio
cloud is a unit
which is part of the master of business
analytics so the students are all
graduate students the unit is
reproducible and collaborative practices
in this unit the students
learn about reproducibility the
importance of reproducibility and
collaborative work
and it's also focused on r we use a lot
of our markdown um
to create reproducible reports and
this unit has also a very heavy emphasis
on the usage of it and github
both
through the um are studio cloud
interface but
and and they are at their interface
and
and also uh using the command line
interface
so these are the units and these are the
students
when i was preparing the units like
about two and a half years ago
um
and and then i revisited these when they
the whole copy pandemy pandemia hit um
i wanted for the students and also for
myself to have a teaching and learning
experience that was efficient and
effective
and i wanted to have a unifying learning
framework where um i could kind of have
some control about how the students
interact with the software with our and
with our studio
i also wanted to remove the installation
and the the first usage burdens
and
of course i i wanted all this to to run
smoothly in a remote or even in a hybrid
learning environment
and also core
to the program was i wanted the students
to have an active learning
and based on the principles of
constructivism where the students are
actually they learn by doing
and i also wanted them to have an
authentic experience i wanted them to
use practical real examples
and
when you are in a remote um
environment
it's actually uh very difficult to to
deal with um
students having different um
computers different access and so on so
having a tool like our studio cloud
allowed me to kind of troubleshoot uh
all the examples make sure everything
runs smoothly and i had like
i had the control to to actually make
sure make sure things work smoothly uh
without having to worry about uh
the type of computer the students have
or um
or how like deal with the issues that
they might have due to the installation
or the the the computer features
all right so i i told you about um the
the two units and that i thought using
our studio cloud but of course these
units are part of a larger program
and so in our um department we all the
units in which we teach are we use rs
studio
or studio cloud in some of them
so it is uh very important for the
students to to understand um
the difference between our
at studio and r studio cloud so even in
the units where i taught um
using r studio cloud
in in the first instance i i the
students are introduced to our anarch
studio and then um
we we bring on our studio cloud the the
integrated development environment in
the cloud as a solution which does not
require the students to install the
program
and in which they could immediately run
a first project in a very smooth way
so the students actually embrace this in
a very easy way and they very much like
it i have to say
especially those students who did not
have any experience coding
and it's quite powerful when you give
them
a url a link and then they go they click
they open our studio cloud and they
suddenly can run the first program and
create like a visualization that is
something quite powerful which the
students um
really enjoy
so in the two units that i mentioned
just now the way in which i approach uh
uh the teaching of r and rs studio um is
a little bit different in the in the
unit of introduction to data analysis i
use artist studio cloud for the entire
semester
and
i will tell you a little bit more about
how do i
organize the unit and and how do i
use studio cloud for the teaching and
learning
in the other unit um the um
collaborative and reproducible practices
i use artist studio cloud in the first
four weeks of the semester so
the students are confident to install
and use r and r studio in their local
machines
and if you remember i mentioned at the
beginning that this unit collaborative
and reproducible practices is very much
focused on reproducibility and on the
usage of git and github
and not only using um
git through the
rstudio
interface but also using the command
line interface
so in this unit and using rstudio for
the first four weeks actually empowers
the students to to feel confident
to install the software in their own
machines and and
start using it locally which is
something very empowering which the
students very much like it especially
those who did not have any prior coding
experience or experience with r
so i will tell you a little bit about
how do i organize um
the units and like this you will better
understand how an artist studio cloud
comes in in into into the unit
so this uh here you are looking at um
the the contents of week three where we
uh teach them the grammar of graphics
and and dates
so a
in
in australia the semester has 12 weeks
and usually uh
we use a learning
management system to
interact with the students
so this is a screenshot of of the
the week three of introduction to to
data analysis
so
for every week uh there is a number of
links related to the material that we
are going to cover where the students
can read um and and and get a bit more
information
and then we have the uh the lecture
and then we have a the
tutorial so let me first uh let you tell
you about how do i run the lectures and
and why do i do it in in the way
i do it
so uh
the lecturers
i use the lectures to introduce the
concepts of the week to the students
and um first i i discuss different
functions that we are going to use
different packages depending on what we
are learning that week
and then during the class i do live
demonstrations
so the code is also in the slide so the
students can
follow and do it at the same time if
they want but it's not essential that
that they do it at the same time i'm
more interested to kind of uh discuss
the the different functions do uh the
demonstration and have a conversation
with the students while
i do that so for the lectures i don't
use rstudio cloud i use rstudio
and in my experience it's actually quite
important to
when we use our studio cloud to keep
this connection between
the cloud and the local interface right
because um
some of the things that i have
experienced i have run these uh units
now for uh two years
so um
if if i if during the lectures i only
focus on our studio cloud some of the
students they have kind of problems
later on understanding
you know that you can have r and r
studio in your local machine and is the
same but the way you access is a little
bit different instead of clicking in the
in the url you have to open it in your
computer look for your files and so on
so
i during the lectures i do i use r and r
studio locally
and then during the tutorials which are
um
the part of the unit where is hands-on
and we do all the exercises and the
practice we use um
at a studio cloud like this i i find i
get kind of like
the good of both worlds and the students
are familiar about how do i interact in
my local machine and in some instances
some of them they also install it in the
machines
and um at the same time they see the
connection with with rstudio cloud
so that is for the lecture uh so each
week we have tutorials which they run
for two hours and as i said they are
focused on the materials and that we
have covered
in the lecture so they are the tutorial
is is hands-on we have a number of
exercises and then um the students work
um
they are divided in groups of about 25
of them and they work work through the
exercises with um
led by the teaching associate
so one thing that we do which we found
is quite useful is um we create each
week we create um
videos
for the tutorial so let me
first
tell you about what are the materials
that we provide the students
for the tutorials so
for each tutorial we give the students
a pdf which i will show you um in a
minute a pdf with um all the
the exercises
that they are going we are going to
cover in the tutorial and also with the
link to the rstudio cloud space
so that's the pdf that you see there for
example week three tutorial
before uh
so right after the lecture we also
launched a video which is um
in in the video we teach the students
for example in the first week we just uh
we recorded a five minutes video where
um
one of my teaching associates uh
really create a wonderful
video where she um
she walks the students through the
access
and
to the cloud right so in each um
for the video
in
in each week
we give them an introduction about okay
this is these are the exercises that we
are going to do
we are going to click in this link that
will take us to the rs studio cloud
express space for the unit and then
that's where we start with the exercises
so the video kind of aims at giving them
like a like a heads up about what is
going to happen in the tutorial
so these
are kind of like some screenshots
a couple of screenshots about the pdf
that i was talking
just now
so if you see uh we have the contents so
in this case we are going to run four
exercises and the works of objectives
and then the instructions
so if you see there that is follow this
link here so
when the students click on the link they
are
taken to the space of the unit
so uh and then once they access the
space uh the unit space you see below
that's what they see in this case is etc
10 10 55 10 and then they can access the
the workshop or the tutorial uh over
there so each week and we
we we provide them with this material
and at the end of the week in the same
in space in our studio cloud we provide
them with the solutions
typically the workshop um
the workshop tutorial
is the same thing
um
so we give them
i think i have it here
we we
once they access the the the material in
the other studio cloud for that
particular week's tutorial
what they they have is something like
what you see on the screen
we
still they have the pdf with the
instructions and then they have um they
are markdown files the data and so on so
we typically give them an skeleton
and then they have the pdf with the
instructions of the things that they
need to do to complete the tutorial and
if you see in the top uh left corner
that is the space
that i create at the beginning of the
semester for
the the tutorials for this unit
so the students uh i share a link with
them they access the space and then for
the rest of the semester every week they
go to the same link
unless if for some reason i need to
update the link and then in that case i
let them know through the learning
management management system
all right so um
in terms of the the teaching team so i'm
the chief examiner and also the lecturer
and i have i have to say a fantastic
group of teaching associates ah they
really they are a wonderful
group which help which i think really
makes the the teaching and learning
experience for the students
um
a really wonderful one
so when using our studio cloud it's not
different from maybe other when you
teach all the units but i feel um it is
very important to have always an open
communication channel so the way in
which um
i organize the rs studio cloud
for these units is there is an
administrator for the space which is
myself
and then um my head tutor has also admin
rights to the to the space
and
so the other uh teaching associates they
don't typically have admin rights and
that's like
i want to minimize any possible um issue
that might happen if someone change
something uh within the other studio
cloud space without intending to do so
so um
[Music]
they they what we do is um we create the
rs studio cloud space for the unit which
is where the students
work and access
and then we create a clone of that which
we call a
the tr the teaching associate rstudio
cloud space
where um
the teaching associates they have the
same materials also they they have the
solutions
um
and everybody there has admin right so
they can play around
um
however
in the in the unit space only the head
teaching associate has the admin rights
so if there is some like major issue
um they can they cannot the other
teaching associates they can either
contact me or or the
[Music]
um the head tutor
this is how the teaching associate at
the studio cloud space look like so
they
you can see they are the admin
the members they are all they all have
admin rights and one thing that um
we we experienced that is it's kind of
like it's nothing major but i think is
something that i would like to just
point out for maybe some of you who
might want to use
this um when i first create the space
for the teaching associates
i share the the i send them a link to
the space right and and then they joined
the space
but uh what we have what happened
once it was that one of the the teaching
associates share the link with the
students to this space where all the
material with the solutions are there
so
these things can happen because when the
students at first they start to use our
studio cloud sometimes
in general it goes very smoothly when
they you send them the link to the space
and they join but sometimes there are
some
issues and then you have they cannot
find the link and then you you you give
them the link so anyway there could be a
confusion when you have more than one
space so what i do
is for the teaching associates once they
all join the space i change the the
the way in which uh
members can join this space to
invitation required just to avoid any
issue
the teaching associates for the unit
space they are either contribute
contributors or moderators so the reason
for this is that some of the teaching
associates at first they feel um a
little bit worried that they might
change
some things in the main um
project uh for the tutorial for example
and they don't want to have moderator
rights but they prefer to be
contributors and that's okay um
this is an option and i'm i'm quite
happy with other way and as um
as i mentioned just now um
we we it is important to kind of
have an open channel for communication
so in our case we have weekly meetings
and we always have a slack channel open
for any any issues that they require
admin um rights they can always contact
me or or
my head tutor
to deal with those
all right so
we also use rs studio cloud for
assessment
and so uh
we have one space for the tutorials as
well as i described just now and we have
another space where the students join
for the assignments during the semester
um so the assignments i i share them
with
i share with them
the information via the learning
management system and in the same
fashion as with the tutorials then they
receive a link and then then they go to
the rstudio cloud space and then they
start working from there
when they finish their assignment they
download the project from are studio
cloud and they upload it into
um
into the learning management system
under assignments so so we can keep
track of the submissions and and
everything and we can always
in our studio cloud we can always go and
pick in their projects and and see what
they have been doing in the cloud once
they have submitted the assignment
we also use our studio
cloud for the group work that we have in
the units and also i run a semester
assessment with all the students
so the assignments i launched them via
the learning management system in our
case we we use a moodle
and and it's something i create an
assignment for those of you who are
familiar with moodle but any any of the
other learning management system works
the same way i create the assignment
and then there is a link that takes them
to the assignment rstudio cloud space
and then
then the students they click on the
assignment and and they start working on
the project so you can see there for
example 265 projects were derived from
assignment one
they work in the assignment they
download the project and then they
submit it in
into the learning management system also
the reason why i ask them to download
the project and submit it is i want to
also
kind of make sure the project hasn't
changed after the submission date in our
studio club
so the other piece of assessment that i
do using rstudio cloud which uh
the first year was a little bit like it
has worked very well the two years i
made it but the first year um it was a
bit nerve-wracking to have almost 300
students doing this assessment at the
same time and everything had to run
smoothly
and
as i said the first year was a little
bit more nerve-wracking the second year
it ran really smoothly so this semester
assessment is a time exercise that runs
over two hours
so
it's kind of like an exam if you if you
wish um
i launched it uh via um
the learning management system so for
this as i and this piece of assessment i
create a different
artist studio cloud space
in which i invite the students before to
make sure everyone has access
they have once they access the
it is time and is this the same time for
all the students
they they start working on the
assignment in our studio cloud and then
once they complete the assignment they
download the project with all the files
and they submit it again in um
via the learning management um system
so
in order to to
to deal with any possible technical
issues we have a zoom open a zoom call
open
and for technical support so the zoom
call is not open for the students or
like to try to get help about the
exercise no it's just for technical
support so if someone
um
like is that they usually
there are not many issues but sometimes
some students they get they keep being
kicked out of their project and
sometimes i have to kind of download
delete them and create like give them
access again but that's really a
minority as i said it runs very smoothly
by having um
this zoom call open it gives the
students the peace of mind that if
something happen
um they can always contact us
so just just to wrap it up some thoughts
um
are studio cloud really i think is great
for
um
to kind of to to to lead
students in the first r journey it
removes the installation burdens and it
actually kind of it avoids the the
problem of dealing with different
operating system or computers with
different specs
it definitely facilitates the remote and
online learning because um
i can always see like other students you
know cloning the project are they
working and if some students have some
issue i can always speak in their
project which is really good
um
also it gives you kind of like a
flexibility to decide um how the users
access and the different projects in
in terms of how much ram do you need or
cpus so if you are working with real
life examples you can always make sure
um things work before you kind of open
the exercise to the students and you if
you need you can adjust those parameters
um
i think one thing that is very important
is to actually keep the connection but
for people like us who are more used to
use rs studio it's kind of it it seems
obvious right there is a connection
between r studio cloud and rs studio but
when the students they are first um
started their journey into learning r if
we only focus on our studio cloud
what i have experienced is some of them
have trouble understanding what is an
art project because when i
when when i give them a link they
already access they are already in the
project so sometimes at the beginning
when they are learning it's a little bit
confusing that's why i i try to to use
are studio in my um
desktop for the lectures and added
studio cloud for the practical exercises
so the students see how the two things
are almost the same but it's slightly
different in the way you access to it
mainly because i don't want them to be
confused with what is on our project
and i think it's a very empowering tool
especially you know like in the other
unit the reproducible and collaborative
practices
i want them to build confidence to
install the the software in the local
machine and to also use the the command
line interface and and also interact
with it through the rstudio
interface so i i find that is really
empowering and some of them they really
love the the possibility to go back to
our studio cloud and try different
things with different art versions
without having to install all of them in
their computer so it's quite good
so just as a final thought like i always
think
um about the the teaching and learning
experience is a little bit like fine
dining right it's not only about the
food but it's also about the experience
and that's where i think ari studio
cloud brings a lot to to to to students
that are first learning art
and with this i would like to thank you
all for your attention and take any
questions that you may have or any
comments thank you
hey patricia that was great thank you so
much really um learned a lot took a
bunch of notes along the way and i see
we've actually had a lot of
questions uh trickling in sorry for the
loud uh lawnmower outside um
the the first question that i think we
should jump into if i'm following the
order correctly
is uh regarding your experience with
github let me just pop this up on the
screen
so
uh can you talk a little bit about um if
you did have to prime students at all or
if they came to the table with get
experience
oh no no and actually the students they
had no experience so some of them they
have no experience even coding are i
would say the majority so i i
they have to learn
our rs studio and they need to also
learn git and github
and um in that unit i def
my focus is that the students learn to
use git through the command line
interface so they also use i teach them
kind of like to use git and github
through the rstudio interface also
through the command line interface
um
and the reason for that is that if you
if you learn how to use git through the
command line interface you can use git
with r with matlab with python with
whatever you want so i want them to have
that flexibility so i teach them
everything from scratch
perfect
just looking through the next questions
here
i think this is a great one to surface
if you can speak to your use of the
functionality that allows you as the
instructor to access the project of the
students
yes yes that is actually that is a great
feature from our studio cloud
and
so let me can you can you all still see
my slides
yes okay perfect let me just go back
quickly um
[Music]
so this is uh like what you see on the
screen now that's what i see as an
instructor
and you see over here it says view 265
derived projects if i click there what i
see is uh it's the project of each of
the students right so if i let's say if
i want to to go and and look at the
particular project of a particular
student i just simply look for in the
members space look for the name of the
student and then i will have the list of
all the
the the projects the student has and
then i can simply click
on their project and i will see i will
have their project in my in my screen so
it's very
it's very
easy to to access
the students project and that's
something also very useful if they
really
i don't tend to overuse it because i
want them to to create a reproducible
example if they have a problem where i
can't help them but if they really are
really stuck and i need to go and pick
in their project i can do it that way
which is it really very smooth and and
and very helpful
thank you
um i just want to say thanks to martin
monkman i i see you put some very
helpful comments uh in here so i
appreciate that uh it also prompts me to
to want to hear patricia's perspective
on this uh the question uh patricia is
basically what was the budget approval
process for a tool like rstudio cloud or
other
tools that you use what was that like uh
at monash
right so um
when i decided to use our studio cloud
and first we had a conversation with uh
pete and the team
um i mean first i wanted to see what
were the capabilities was this one
suitable for our students and pete at
the team were really very very helpful
and and then um
our
school manager kind of discussed um the
the pricing and the product that we
needed so everything happened through
our department
um so it was in our case it was quite
smooth i i remember at first we also had
a discussion with the it department at
monas to decide whether we wanted to use
the rstudio cloud server or we wanted to
use the server at monas and in the end
it turned out that it was it was easier
and it would it would work out better
for us to use the server at monas and
that's how we kind of
we we decided to go ahead so the the
budget process
first i kind of um
i
discussed with pete and the team to see
if the specs were
aligned to what i needed then i
discussed with um with the department
manager and the head of the department
and then from there they discuss
um the pricing and the funding and
everything else with beat anything i
hope this answers your question
yes yes no thank you hopefully that was
helpful for some of our guests tuning in
today um
i think there's a few other good
questions that have trickled in here
let's uh let's surface this one
how does our studio cloud differ from
our studio server a lecturer may set up
his or her own rstudio server maybe
using a vm then give access to their
students to work online on their r
studio account
right right yeah that's a possibility of
course it adds more work
to you to the lecturer and so i haven't
used it in that that way i i just i use
our studio cloud using our studio cloud
server but that
what you are mentioning is what i i i
was discussing just now that we first
talked with our i.t department if we
could create that um
like a server at monash to use that in
our case for our needs we we prefer to
use our studio cloud server but you
could potentially do that and i'm sure
peter and the team can like tell you
more about that
yeah absolutely the other thing i'd add
that i think this next question i just
shared really touches on is that our
studio cloud and our studio server or or
workbench are not actually exactly the
same so our studio cloud does offer
additional features and capabilities
that you don't find with the other
offerings that are um
that lend themselves
in particular to academic teaching so
the notion of a workspace you can think
of that as a virtual classroom that
doesn't exist in the other our studio
offerings
the ability to actually shell out
assignments and to kind of peek into
your students work
that's also specific to our studio cloud
there's some other differences as well
uh but just want to make sure that's
clear that our studio cloud does have
specific capabilities uh that really
help you teach and learn that that you
won't find in the other our studio
offerings now outside of the actual
features the other thing to think about
is rstudio cloud is a hosted sas
offering meaning we're hosting it for
you so from an infrastructure
perspective you don't have to worry
about having servers or having the
correct i.t
colleagues that can manage those servers
we're handling that all for you so
sometimes
when you look at it from that
perspective it's just going to be a lot
easier to
to roll out and administer
let's see we have a bunch of questions
here here's another one related to
github
what about pushing to a managed repo
do you teach that as well
sorry
what about pushing to a managed repo
like github do you teach that as well
yes yes so the students they they learn
how to use git to to create the the
repository and then we store like i
teach them to a store that in artist in
github and they could use other um
remote repository but yeah yeah
they they learn all that in the in the
um in the course i i just wanted to to
mention that i realized i forgot to make
the the github um repository with the
slides public so i'm going to do it
right now and so
yeah no problem and i do see that some
folks are asking about getting access to
the slides patricia has been very nice
and has agreed to share all this
material so we will ensure
to get that out to all of you
um
go ahead patricia sorry
yeah so i'm just making the the ripple
sorry about that i forgot to do it this
morning
okay so yeah you should be able to
access the the github repository with
all the materials for the slides
um in the link
that is there on the on the slides yeah
perfect um
i also wanted to
jump into a comment or a question that
was made earlier around an academic
completely free version of our studio
cloud so just to clear that up there is
a free tier of our studio cloud that's
actually free for anyone regardless of
if you're an academic or maybe you know
working within an institution such as
you know a corporate company or maybe
you're just freelancing on your own as a
consultant there is a free tier that
you're more than welcome to use it is a
little bit limited in terms of the
amount of time and the amount of people
you can collaborate with uh but if
you've never used cloud it's a great way
to get started and depending on your
teaching use case um
depending on how large it is it could
actually address that as well
outside of the free tier there are
various paid versions of rcdo cloud now
if you're using it for an academic
degree granting institution
like patricia's use case there is a
heavy discount essentially a 95 plus
percent discount since we're we're
basically just passing on our hosting
cost um and we're happy to uh have those
conversations with each of you if you
have a use case that you'd like to run
by us
digging back into some of these
questions let me find another good one
to pose
well one question that i actually had
i think it's great that you
really spoke to the the very relevant
pandemic nature and um how our studio
cloud was able to help along with the
idea of using this with undergraduate
and graduate programs
and then i forget if you went into it or
if i might just know this from our past
conversations but i know you had a use
case where maybe you had 30 60 students
and then another where you had closer to
300 students maybe you could speak a
little bit to um you know how our studio
cloud scaled uh for those use cases
right yeah
well i have to say it scales
really really well
because um once you create the the this
the other studio cloud space for a unit
you share that space through a link
through a url right and then it doesn't
really matter if you have 30 students so
if you have 300 students
and they all just go and click on the
url link and they join the space
um so in terms of the students accessing
the array studio cloud space it
definitely scales up really well
and no issues there
and then of course
the issues come is not the same to have
30 students with 30 questions that to
have 300
and
but those are more about the content
rather than the the other studio cloud
itself so i would say the skills are
very well
i love hearing that i i'm going to
surface a question regarding markdown
say something about instructing markdown
specifically i have found this actually
the most difficult uh for students
right right um yes yes and
it's kind of it's interesting because um
in in a way markdown is very simple but
students struggle a little bit at the
beginning so the the way i approach um
the beginning of the of the unit first i
i teach them about r and like for
example in introduction to to data
analysis we discuss our our commands and
then we talk a little bit about
reproducibility and then how we can
integrate um
code with text to create a report
um so that's kind of like
i introduced this sequentially so they
understand why
do we need our markdown or markdown and
and what are the benefits of it and it
works quite well
and in the unit the the
reproducibility and unit that one i i
start straight away into our markdown
so students who don't have a lot of
knowledge of r
at first they they
kind of like yeah they need some time to
get the the head around but it like i do
the same thing as i do in the other unit
just a little bit faster because this
unit reproducible and collaborative
practices is more focused on
reproducibility and and and creating
reports creating slides and using our
and our markdown
with git
to create version control projects and
and with github
thank you i think that was probably very
helpful for for folks listening in
um
let's see
i'm having trouble locating it to bring
it up on the screen but i know earlier
someone did ask about uh the actual
grading experience um so how you went
about grading assignments and maybe if
there was any type of integration with
an lms um i believe you might use moodle
there any um
insight you can share on that front
right so
in the way that i i didn't use anything
that integrate artist studio cloud with
uh the the moodle system so the way i i
did the grading for the assignment and
for the assessments is the students and
they work on their assignment using
rstudio cloud and then once they have
finished the their assignment
which is contained in an in an art
project in rstudio cloud they download
that project into a zip folder and then
they upload the zip folder into the
into moodle so like this i can see um
who has submitted and they submitted if
it's on submitted on time and so on and
then what we do is um we ask the
students also to um
in addition to submit the the zip folder
with the art project
they also need to submit the url of the
project like this we avoid the the
trouble to have to look through the 300
students to um
to find the project so once we have the
link we just click and we can directly
go straight away into their project so
per se i haven't used like an
integration
that kind of brings the markings
straight away into model so we kind of
we have the assignment and then we mark
the assignment and upload the the grades
in the grades and the feedback
on
in model
great thank you i know that comes up a
lot with conversations that i have with
various instructors and deans that are
trying to
um incorporate our studio cloud uh into
uh the various courses um
i i see that someone did ask about a
collaboration feature and in the past
they heard our studio cloud was going to
be working on that so the good news is
we have been
heavily working on that so if anyone's
familiar with the experience on
workbench or or our studio server where
you have a
a google doc-like experience where
multiple people can
edit and collaborate on the code in real
time with different colored cursors we
are going to be bringing that in our
studio cloud the hope is we'll have that
available by the end of this quarter so
um
please uh keep that in mind and once it
is available we'd love your feedback if
you're able to get your hands on it
um the
next question
we have here i think this uh was touched
on earlier but just in case uh it's
helpful someone did ask how do i get
started talking to my college dean in
i.t about the possibility of hosting our
studio cloud
i know within some institutions it
involves you know first talking to your
chair
but
if you don't mind reiterating how you
went about that patricia
um
well i guess you will need to make a
case right um
so what i did is
i kind of um
i look about what are studio cloud could
offer that would be useful for for the
units that i was teaching and i kind of
did like pros cons and and they kind of
brought a document
um with um
with the reasons why i wanted to use
that and why i thought it was something
worth to invest
on and yeah it was it was quite i have
to say
um yeah our department is quite uh pro r
and rs studio and they kind of they
embrace it with no problem
that's great to hear
um and if others listening in are also
wondering about this and you'd like some
hands-on help
myself along with a few other of us on
the r studio team have had a lot of
experience helping
academic administrators
um professors uh if you will kind of
navigating that process so so do feel
free to reach out uh and we're happy to
have that conversation another question
that i had is
i um
i i'm just curious this hybrid approach
i know you mentioned the idea of
starting in cloud for one of the courses
to help lower the barrier to entry um
and essentially doing that for the first
four weeks and then getting
those particular students probably for
that type of course to learn how to
install and set up
have you found that since you adopt a
cloud
for that actual use case that it's been
a lot simpler for students as opposed to
from day one having to deal with
troubleshooting
yeah absolutely i i really like this the
hybrid approach
because it really the students who have
no experience they are very nervous at
the beginning not to mention that in
that unit in addition to learning our rs
studio
and reproducibility they need to also
learn
you to use the command line interface
git and github
so uh to use rstudio cloud the first
four weeks and it really
it makes things very easy because they
feel when they are in the cloud is kind
of a safe environment they just click on
the project the project opens everything
runs you know everything is there for
them they learn there are different
versions of our how to install packages
but everything is kind of in a contained
environment where nothing really can
go very wrong
right so that's what once they have used
it for several weeks for a few weeks
they really feel very confident and we
don't transition from
like
black to white right we
the first four weeks we use our studio
cloud and then we we slowly transition
to use it on the
on the desktop so it really
it really helps
great i'm just going to surface uh
because i know it's been asked a couple
times now the actual link just so folks
can easily grab it to these slides so
that's a live link i just put up there
that patricia was so kind to share
let's see we have a few more minutes
maybe for one or two more questions
um
all right here's here's a good one that
uh
i think is always fun to talk about very
challenging for me to convince folks
that r is not an instead of python
frustrating uh any you know insight
you'd like to share around there
well
i have to say in our department we don't
have uh this challenge because um we
mostly use r for for for
almost all the units
um
i don't know i i think
maybe we should put aside this r versus
python maybe python is good for
sometimes and r is another studio is
good for for some others so i think
um
yeah i'm more like of
there are there are good things in both
so i i you know this is like the eternal
kind of
conversation and i really don't have
like a very good answer other than
well if you want to convince someone to
use r versus python i i guess you again
you will need to make a case why in this
instance are is better or is it better
suited for what you are teaching
and
also
once you know a programming language is
much easier to learn another one so you
know i don't think someone learns r and
only our and not any other programming
languages
right so
i i don't have a solution for that
that's fine if i can uh interject with
my own uh
experience dealing with this question
working for our studio as you can
imagine at various conferences that we
attend this comes up often uh so for
folks who don't know a few years ago we
we decided to actually embrace the
python community uh so on the r studio
uh on-prem products like workbench
you're actually able to um to integrate
with jupiter lab or jupyter notebook
so it's kind of either or you can come
to our studio and use either
currently that experience is actually in
beta on our studio cloud so if you
haven't checked it out and you have a
python use case you can do that in our
studio cloud um it'll
open up a jupyter notebook if you'd like
and we're hoping if things go well to
take that uh that beta experience into
general availability by the end of this
quarter as well um so i i did see
someone mentioned that they're having
trouble getting budget for rstudio cloud
because the school really favors python
keep in mind that now you can use our
studio cloud for for those python use
cases as well
um
i think
a
another couple questions came through
but due to time we'll probably just jump
into one of these let me
okay here here's a good question
in the past i have had students pick
some data sets maybe crime data and by
the end of the semester create a report
based off their chosen data set do you
use the same data set for all
no
no no no and
we have like in every in every lecture
and every week we use different data
sets and also for the assignments
there are some instances that maybe
we have done some data wrangling for a
particular data set at the beginning of
the semester and then when we go and
study about linear models we would use
that data set in a different context but
in general we use different data sets
which are like real life examples for
each week and for each assessment
perfect so uh i see there's some more
questions here we'll try to address
these offline really appreciate um
everyone joining us today especially you
patricia this was a great presentation
um
and uh just for folks tuning in next
week we will actually be holding a live
demo uh our colleague mine who has done
a lot of the r studio cloud content to
date we'll be offering a live demo
january 21st i believe that's next
thursday
so please join us again and
have a great rest of your day thank you
thank you